my name is will yakowitz i'm a staff
writer here at forbes magazine and i
cover vices which is a collection of
beats i cover the the cannabis industry
the gambling industry and sex three
years into the pandemic something became
very clear that americans
generally speaking have really leaned
into good old-fashioned bad behavior you
know the pandemic caused a lot of stress
and anxiety not to mention the horrific
human toll it had on on the u.s in order
to deal
with this new reality a lot of americans
you know took up their various vices and
crutches so we saw cannabis use go up we
saw alcohol use go up gambling and you
know with new streaming platforms like
only fans we saw could porn consumption
also go up as stay-at-home orders swept
across the country in march 2020 a
couple things happened alcohol sales
jumped 10
and also for the year
cigarette sales jumped for the first
time in 20 years so the bump these
industries saw during covid has not
stopped it's really this new normal that
that we've seen americans have leaned
into vices and
they are sticking with them
the pandemic was a boon to the cannabis
industry dispensaries were deemed
essential businesses which was important
if you guys remember march 2020
everything was closed except for grocery
stores pharmacies and liquor stores
right the distinction of a dispensary
being deemed essential was was huge so
it's no surprise that cannabis sales
increased 46
from 2019 to 2020 and as of last year
sales hit 25 billion not only was there
a bump due to covid legalization has
been spreading for years and we're now
reaching like a crescendo federal
legalization is on the horizon two
interesting things about consumer
behavior to note during the pandemic
perhaps unsurprisingly edible sales went
up around 50
uh compared to pre-pandemic levels that
jump um could be seen as obvious right
there was a deadly respiratory virus so
a lot of people leaned into edibles
instead of smoking as the pandemic wore
on pandemic fatigue increased pre-rolled
joint sales increased 47 compared to
pre-pandemic levels you know some of
these these consumer behaviors make
perfect sense like edible is going up
but the others kind of don't nearly a 50
percent spike in joint sales is is
pretty remarkable and interesting
[Music]
the start of the pandemic was a little
rocky for the gaming industry casinos
were shuttered for months due to
lockdown orders gross gaming revenue in
nevada dropped from 12 billion in 2019
to 7.8 billion in 2020 and it really
looked like it was a losing proposition
for the entire industry as covid
restrictions eased and vaccines were
rolled out what we saw is that americans
flocked to sin city and they were
spending their stimulus checks uh on
gambling what was you know it started
off to be a disaster really turned into
a 10-month winning streak for nevada by
the end of 2021 nevada hit a new state
record hitting 13.4 billion in gross
gaming revenue for the year so americans
were cooped up for months right and then
as these covid restrictions eased people
wanted to travel americans really
american gamblers picked up the slack
it's easy to get to vegas right but it's
even easier to get to your regional
casino so those casinos have seen big
bumps in revenues as well
if you guys remember the beginning of
the pandemic sports were cancelled
you know gamblers were really
hard-pressed to find anything to bet on
uh in the beginning people were betting
on like table tennis and and funny
sports like that but then eventually
sports returned and what we saw is that
sports betting really became another
national pastime as states were eager
for tax revenue they embraced sports
betting one state in particular that
that i think really highlights kind of
the fervor
around sports betting and the growth of
the industry is new york new york
launched its mobile sports betting
program in january and within two weeks
the total handle surpassed one billion
dollars which is just a mind-boggling
number by february new yorkers wagered
over three billion dollars analysts say
that they do not see the growth in in
gambling and specifically sports betting
contracting anytime soon society is now
accepting of sports betting it's not
this back room you know cigar smoking
type deal it is a thing that you can do
on your couch with your smartphone while
all this growth is good for companies
there are some naysayers a veteran
sports bettor bill krakenberger told me
that he does not think the the
mainstreaming of sports betting is a
good thing in general uh his prediction
is in 10 years time you will not be able
to get a seat at a gambler's anonymous
meeting he he thinks this um
proliferation of sports betting and the
ease and the social acceptance is just
going to lead more and more people down
gambling addiction
the adult content industry also was
transformed during the pandemic during
the height of kovid a lot of sex workers
stopped seeing clients in person and
there were platforms that have already
been been building um building up steam
and building up audiences like only fans
and is my girl fan centro a lot of sex
workers turned to online platforms to
continue working more people were home
more people were alone and um you know
when you're cut off from society when
you're cut off from your friends and
family and loved ones you know
sex is a human need right just like
people turned to smoking a joint or or
drinking at home alone a lot of people
turned to porn for intimacy or just
stimulation frankly what we saw was
companies like only fans fan centro and
other streaming platforms exploded in
popularity both on the consumer end and
on the creator end you can't talk about
the the adult streaming market without
talking about only fans it is the
billion dollar tech company that porn
built seemingly overnight only fans
attracted 180 million users and 2
million content creators and to date 2
million creators on only fans have
earned 5 billion in subscription fees
the company itself saw its revenue
skyrocket 540 percent
hitting 400 million dollars by the end
of 2020.
the popularity of only fans cannot be
overstated everybody from
you know a former pastor to porn stars
like sophie d to
mainstream musicians like cardi b are on
that platform only fans is a really
fascinating case study in what happens
to businesses when they serve markets
like adult content so as only fans
became a multi-billion dollar company
they they started looking for outside
funding and they were having a hard time
doing that a lot of investors are
skittish around porn they also hit a few
roadblocks with payment processors you
know a lot of payment processors like
visa and mastercard have general morals
that you know they they won't process
payments for illegal transactions um and
some even you know have a hard line with
adult content so only fans tried to
pivot away from porn and it was a
disaster you know a lot of the creators
were up in arms a lot of the users were
up in arms the decision to pivot back to
porn if you will was really the only way
forward for only fans what only fans
created um and other platforms like it
is a more intimate relationship between
the viewer and the creator
if you are looking at like old school
pornographic films right like on a set
there there's distance between the
viewer and and the creator the porn
stars right the distance has been erased
and that is really transformed like
appetites for for people who are looking
for adult content and i don't think
that's going to change how people make
money in the industry and how people
consume adult content has been changed
forever
[Music]
there are many different reasons and
forces at play here two of the most
interesting to me are this this general
nihilism that that has really kind of
taken over this generation of people who
are either coming to age or becoming
adults in in the pandemic
people are embracing stress relievers
right but also there's this other thing
that i think is even a stronger force is
the social acceptance and the
legalization you know legalization of
sports betting legalization of cannabis
the social acceptance of adult content
and all these forces really make it okay
to do these things and so i think people
are responding by doing exactly that by
doing these things for now you know
these economies are economies of scale
every new state that opens up for
cannabis and gambling that is
millions and millions of dollars in tax
revenue but also sales for these
companies these industries are really
not going to slow down anytime soon
you